I would say a few words about my father
but don't worry unlike Lionel I won't go
on all night long
[Music]
the royal family was joined by a crowd
of 20 000 fans on the castle grounds
virtually Pierce Brosnan Hugh Jackman
and Tom Cruise sent their well wishes to
the new king
[Music]
man anytime on his first full day as
King Charles already made a mark on his
Reign drafting Kermit the Frog Miss
Piggy and Winnie the Pooh for
appearances instead of Queen Elizabeth's
favorite Paddington Bear
Charlotte had a blast dancing singing
along and waving their Flags during the
15 performances but their brother well
Louis wasn't there but of course he's
only five and that concert started well
after his bedtime
the king asked
this song you will never walk alone
the lyrics are an encouragement for
himself I think
tell us about performing with Nicole
scherzing I really like the the high
note she's doing in the end
what was it like backstage it was so
warm it was giddy almost Katy Perry uh
Nicole another Richie he was loving it
Lionel was just absolutely loving
Alexis French and Zach Abel's
performance featured a drone show of
animals above the stage also lighting up
the sky Katy Perry with a lion
Charlotte sang along as Katie performed
two hits her stunning gold gown was
actually inspired by Vivian Westwood's
Bridal collection and came with this
hidden tribute stitched in the bodice
and while Orlando posted his reaction
saying so proud from home the pop star
did have another special guest in the
audience I got to bring my mom she is so
happy to be here
a line on Katie were across the pond
guest judges Alanis Morissette and Ed
Sheeran filled in for them here at
American Idol but the biggest surprise
of the night an appearance from King
Charles and queen Camilla surprise I
have a surprise I just wanted to check
um how much how long you'll be using
this room for I was driving in and my
phone rings as executive producer and
she says well we've got some news so
Lionel actually asked the king at a tea
party this afternoon about potentially
doing it today today it all happened
today you know I had always thought that
Lionel Richie was lying about his
relationship with his majesty but Lionel
I know for sure that you actually do
know the king and queen like you said
you did never doubt Lionel Richie I
gotta say Luke you looked really
comfortable on that middle seat there
Katie's yeah you know like I said there
was a little bit of uh Katie had some
old foundation and some glitter in the
chair from from shows past I missed him
but it was really fun uh being in the
room with with Ed and Alana's
it's going to take a few weeks for me to
process this last night the final eight
contestants performed Atlantis and Ed's
hits including Thinking Out Loud which
was at the center of the copyright
infringement lawsuit Ed won last week
[Music]
I was just loving these Renditions
mention his courtroom Victory on the
show but he did make a pit stop on the
way to Idol he's popping around La doing
these shows on Starlight I passed this I
passed the big line coming in I thought
maybe oh there's a sale it turns out was
Ed Sheeran on a bus
[Music]
thank you